let's read this first story and talk
about what's going on we got this from
timcast.com Australia sends mixed
signals on who is permitted to enter the
country deports Katie Hopkins they say
despite a uh permitting the arrival
despite permitting the arrival of
celebrities come on Tim Cass get a copy
editor the government has not brought
home 40 000 Australians now the article
basically goes on to mention that there
are many celebrities flying in like you
know uh you've got to what they say
Nicole Kidman flew in you have Lachlan
Murdoch and um Keith Urban we're among
the elite group have been allowed to
travel back to the country by a private
plane they were also permitted to
quarantine at their private homes they
go in a mention that uh where's there we
go British commentator Katie Hopkins who
was also in Australia to film big
brother was deported for comments she
made online about breaking the corn uh
countries quarantine regulations
so we've seen a lot of this lockdown
stuff going on and now basically the
story is Australia is prolonging its
covid-19 lockdown in Victoria amid the
Delta outbreak so this is the excuse by
which they're saying everyone's got to
quarantine again if you're flying into
the country and it kind of um
I got I gotta say it is it is awfully
convenient if you are a proponent of the
great reset are you familiar with the
group absolutely it's it's awfully um
fortuitous I suppose for those who are
fans of the great reset and those who
have advocated for it that uh we can't
travel to places anymore that people are
deported if they you know they break
quarantine I get it the country has laws
Australia's allowed to deport what they
want I suppose but now they're
prolonging this now there's fears of of
uh you know the Delta uh the Delta
variant outbreak and I'm just you know
I'm curious you mentioned um
in the in the intro we're talking about
people fleeing these cities
what's your what's your uh I guess your
prediction on where we are
um
you know I've got some thoughts about
the current month in the current year uh
but we were talking before the show
rolled about you know I think the world
is changing in a really fundamental and
big way and the kind of thing that you
don't see every year I mean sure things
change you know one year in the next uh
but you know I think that every 500
years or so things really really change
and we saw that you know uh around 500
years ago with the invention of the
printing press which led to the rise of
protestantism and religious wars and
then eventually the westphalian nation
states coming up and replacing feudalism
and you know I think the internet and
the new modes of communication
technology right now are you know and
this isn't a story from like last year
or two years it's you know the 30 years
50 years but the world is really
changing fundamentally and I think we're
going to see changes at about the same
scale so I think that people are
escaping the cities right now and that's
going to accelerate over the coming
years uh but that's just one component
of a much bigger change in currency and
Lifestyles and economies and how you
know States and people are organized on
the planet do you think it's uh
intentional like there are people who
are actively trying to kill off cities
obviously well you know there's
intention out there and there's emergent
stuff I don't think that the elites uh
who are pushing the great reset and the
whole you know live in the Pod eat the
bugs uh want people to escape the cities
you know they're saying hey uh you know
our system is already 80 uh along and we
just need to tune it a little more we
need you know more green energy even
though windmills are sort of a terrible
technology and nuclear is much better
and we need more sustainable foods and
by sustainable they're always talking
about bugs uh and never about you know
raising pigs and chickens and you know
eating right right wine barriers they're
saying not to eat pigs and chickens
right right to eat the bugs right right
did you see that story out of Leesburg
Virginia where the the guy was serving
cicadas I didn't know he was like going
into his girl like his side of his house
and picking them off yeah and then I
guess the health department was like
dude you can't pick bugs off the side
you have to serve it to people so we had
he ordered cicadas right now I'm like
but I I guess they were from China so
clearly defeats the purpose right
bugs from the floor ship them in my air
or something yeah right just eat the
centipedes yeah yeah yeah so anyway
sorry you were I don't know oh uh so um
I I think your question was was this
intentional get people to flee the
cities and I think what's intentional is
the great reset the whole endless
propaganda about how eating bugs and
your lifestyle is going to be different
and you're not going to own anything
you're going to rent uh everything and
uh you know I I think that a lot of that
is intentional but I think that we're to
some degree seeing the last gasp of the
current system uh sort of like you know
the Soviets around 1985.
um the current Elites have run out of
any energy I mean the Soviets motivated
their people you know is a terrible
system but there was actual
um Grassroots enthusiasm when you bring
rural electrification to people you know
they're gonna like that even if you're
doing other terrible things when you
educate the sons of dirt farmers they're
gonna like that
um and so the Soviets had some innate
momentum for decades and then eventually
they just played out everything they
could do and then you know they're
talking about the 18th Five-Year Plan
and you know 1986 or something and
everyone knew it was a joke and the
Soviet in the system said you know they
pretend to pay us and we pretend to work
and I I think that you know the last
Bastion of centrally planned uh
communism is you know here in the west
uh so what what is that I mean I'm
joking a little bit and making a
reference to sort of uh menchous mold
bug Curtis yarvin stuff but no but you
mean to say like the current system
we're under everybody knows it's a joke
and I think exactly and that's where I
was going you're right right um you know
uh
you know we've got and don't worry I
know what one can say and not say
um but we've got a Democratic party uh
the Republican Party ceased to be able
to put forward any candidates of its own
sort of ideology and the Democratic uh
party has sort of entirely run out of
steam where they're putting forward
these candidates who it's inevitable
because it's their time and you get
these you know sort of absolute laughing
stocks Hillary Clinton right right
um so and you know uh Joe Biden God help
him does not seem to have all of his
marbles uh in one place he's got like
two marbles right right you know it's a
tragedy
um but this is the last gasp of the
system you know and so they pretend to
have a president and you know we pretend
to respect the system and uh I think
that things are changing um I I like
that joke you know they pretend to
parents who pretend to work they don't
have a president I think the sad thing
is
yeah it's paper thin yeah you know there
there is a presidential Administration
Joe Biden is fumbling bumbling Joe
Trinidad chapter pressure
and you know one thing that I've brought
up on the show uh frequently is that
when he speaks it's very obvious he's
not talking to half the country right
he'll when he he makes references to
coven when he makes references to law
they've basically cut off in terms of
their there was a point where they were
like you know we want to try and make
sure we're getting to the other side to
win those votes now they're like we
don't even care yeah we don't don't care
about this we saw in the in the 1900s
20th century the the fall of like
centrally planned economies very clearly
and now I think we're up against the
centrally planned law lawyering system
and I wonder how we can I like how you
said Polly as opposed to decentralizing
polycentric law and how we would do that
while maintaining a union right how do
you foresee that uh I'm not sure we
maintain a union I mean um you know
every system lists for as long as it
lives uh back in college I double
majored I was computer science but also
Roman history and um one of my
professors I think Barry Strauss had a a
wonderful um last lecture in the
semester one year and uh you know he was
talking about the parallels between the
Roman system and the American system and
uh you know he said a few things that
you know every country ends eventually
uh but also its forms Linger on after
the reality of it has died and uh you
know a lot of people
um you know sort of red gray tribe will
say you know you know America's gone so
far off the rails but we'll get it back
and I'm like you know dude I think
America ended somewhere between 10 and
50 years ago and right now you know we
still have the form of it some some
people argue it ended with the Federal
Reserve I think that's you know I I
don't particularly have the Federal
Reserve bug
um that you know that explains
everything
um but uh but but I can get along with
those guys
um you know I I think that uh there's
good arguments that um oh gosh
not Coolidge anyway I'm blanking in my
earlier Woodrow Wilson yes thank you
very much sir
um and there's another argument to go
further back that Abraham Lincoln and
you know even if freeing the slaves was
a wonderful ideal uh it's interesting
how every other country on the planet
managed to free its slaves without
having a war and killing three percent
of its population yeah and many before
us yeah like the the British Empire
exactly perfect example uh Great Britain
proper I think was in the 1700s was it
like 73 or something or 75 uh I would
have thought it was later than that but
I'll Trust your number I could be wrong
I know that the in in the greater
Commonwealth it was 1833 right right
that's that's the number I had in my
head funny because they freed their
slaves but they still have like
colonized India correctly right right
you know and the United States is an
example of that but I'm you know we
talked about you know we're this
Exemplar For All Mankind this wonderful
free Society where anybody can do
anything you know as long as it's in the
properly approved narrow uh set of
things that are good and free not you
know terrible bad things like you know
uh going to church and having
old-fashioned ideas or owning Firearms
or anything
um and yet we have this crazy system
where members of both parties sort of
support this Imperial War mongering
system where we're fighting in you know
30 or 40 different countries uh so we've
got this representative government and
all these freedoms at home to some
degree while simultaneously we have you
know absolute you know uh um
on on what is the word I'm looking for
uh with without fettered yes unfettered
that'll do uh you know we have this
effective war on anyone we want to and
there's no checks and balances and
there's no civil rights it's crazy to me
how at a certain point the United States
the the politicians stopped actually
implementing policy in this country and
it was actually an argument over what we
should be doing overseas right and we
had a long period of that from I might
look I can't argue for about what
happened before I was born but although
most of my life was just a whole lot of
arguing about what we're going to do to
other people elsewhere right and I long
complained I'm like everybody's coming
up talking about these pipes in Flint
which now I believe are fixed but I'm
like how much money did we spend in
Afghanistan building roads and building
schools so it's weird to me that the
answer to a lot of what the left was
complaining about was simply that we
focused on America first which is
controversial I guess for some strange
reason but but I wanna I wanna go back
to this point about uh you know Katie
Hopkins in Australia because you
mentioned there might not be a union and
so I'm wondering
if these these these countries are
effectively shutting their borders off
they're making it much much more
difficult for anyone to come in what is
it going to look like if if the United
States isn't even going to be a union
but then it's already hard enough for
people to travel it feels like everybody
is becoming more isolation yes
um you know so there's an interesting
thing where things are getting
physically more isolated you know in the
Physical Realm of where can you go at
the same time that distance is becoming
less important and this is the whole
sort of Lexus in the Olive Tree thesis
that you know the world is getting flat
and you know you can Source parts from
wherever and you can you know I work for
a startup that doesn't have a physical
location or decentralized and we've got
people you know all the way from Italy
over to Japan so we've just got this
sort of weird rolling 20-hour clock
um but you know this gets to what I was
saying earlier about uh you know every
500 years or so maybe there's a deep
fundamental change in how Society is
structured now getting to covet I think
that this is a short-term problem
there's you know we sequenced uh
covid-19 in very short order and we came
up with a uh immunization for it in you
know 48 hours and the only thing that
stood in the way was the old you know
nation states and the FDA and the CDC uh
you know doing things like taking four
day weekends uh during the emergency
where you can count the number of people
dying per day but they're so entrenched
in the sort of 1970s Soviet bureaucratic
thing of oh we've all got to get out to
our doctors you know this is you know
Soviet Pioneer Day you can't expect us
to work and save lives and then so I I
think that's proof that the system is
absolutely exhausted and it's just ready
for people to stop believing it thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to see
the full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time